というふうな この煩悩のどのように生まれるかとか確認できるとできます
理解すること だからこの瞑想するとそんな複雑なことを考えませんだけど
ただまあカラスの声にしたっても
ある時は嫌でうるさくて
ある時はそういう音は別に音はあるんだけど
確認もするんだけど 気にならないと
そこで何がわかるんですかね
人間の煩悩と苦しみとかね
これはアダムとイブが間違ったんだからね
生まれてるものじゃないんだと
ただ単にそんなもんやと
その時その時のことだと
結局は物の事っていうのはその瞬間瞬間だけでってことをわかってないんだから
煩悩生まれるだけのことではありますと
で 煩悩生まれたらやっぱり嫌ですよ
それで煩悩あるんだからこそ
人々は哲学を喋ってるんですね
例えば私がいるんですか？という問題
いわゆる私がいるんですかということでは誰もわかってないんですね
この間 アメリカの人かな
電車でほんのちょっとの時間喋ったんだけど
もうその瞬間喋っただけでも
もう前提としてアプリオリとして自分がいるということを言っておいて
もうこれは当たり前だと言って喋り始めるんですよ
このバカなのと喋りませんと
言ったらもう私たちにとっては我々は何でもチェックするんだと
そのアプライラルないんだと
と言ったんだけど それはわからないですよ
その人には どんな人でも私がいるんだ
そんなことは当たり前でしょうに
証拠はいりませんと 思うでしょうね
では私がいるんだったらなぜいるんですか？という問題が生まれるでしょう
どのようにいるべきかという問題が出てくるでしょう
いる私の将来どうなるんでしょうか？という問題が生まれるでしょうね
全てが私がいるんだという固定概念が生まれるんです
じゃあ私がいる それはどういう意味ですかと見れば
それは瞬間瞬間生まれる感情に私私と確認するんだからなんです
痛みは痛みではなくて
私は痛いと ご飯食べて美味しかったらおいしいという味の味覚を確認しないで
なんて幸せですかと 私は
わかってないんですね
ご飯の食べたものの変わりと味に欲が生まれただけですよということを
事故を起こして足が折っちゃったな
骨が折れたならば なんで私は不幸ですかと
そうやって思っちゃうでしょうね
そこで私という概念が生まれてくる
そこにあるのはその瞬間瞬間の感覚
ジューウェーデな そこは確認していないんだからなんです
確認していくと 私っていうのは一分間で 一億人もいるんです
もっと今数えたことはないんだけど
いい加減な数字ですけど
一分間で我々はどれぐらいのことを確認できますか？音も確認できるし
膨らみも確認できるし
痛みも確認できるし それを全部まとめて私と呼んだから
一人ずつ違うでしょうに
音の感覚で痛みの感覚
そこでその人にとっては私がいるというこの前提アプリオリなくなっちゃうんです
それで義がなくなるってことなんです
そこで私がいるという前提あると
私に将来があるか 死後あるかという問題が出てきて
ある人はあるという ある人はないという
いい加減でしょうに 私がいると思った人がいるということは
個体として見たらずっといたんだから
だったらこれから見るんだと
だったら死んでもいるんだというふうに決めるんであって
それは間違いなんです
そこで私がいる いる私には将来はないと
いわゆるあの世はないと思う人が
どういうことかというと
私が実際にいるんだけど
やっぱり子供のとき あんなものを全部忘れちゃったし
あの二十歳のときはこういうバカなことをして
こういうバカなことをしてね
今なんか考えちゃってもう気持ち悪くてね
というふうに全く自分が違うということに気がつくでしょうね
だったらまあボロボロになって死んじゃったら
まあその時はその時で
まあ死んじゃう それで終わっちゃうよと
それで私にはあの世はないと決めちゃう
どちらでも間違いなんです
それで過去を考えて ここに私がいる
なぜいるのでしょうかと
過去を考えちゃうと まあたまたま偶然に生まれたんではないかと
それで偶然論が生まれてくる
あるいは人間の世界を見ると
母親がいて 母親に母親がいたりすると
そうやって追っていっちゃったら
やっぱり誰かが最初に作らなかったら現れないんだと
作るんだったら誰が作ったんでしたと
そうやって思考が生まれてくるんです
あれも間違ってるんです
それで私がいると 見たら
まあずっと私がいるんだから
別に私は人殺したって私は私でしょうし
人を助けたって私は私で大した変わりはないんだと
一時的だと その時は腹が立ったんだから殺したんだけど
腹が立ってないと殺せませんからね
別に自分が変化しないと思っちゃうんです
自分という実感が 故に
別にそういう善悪行為には結果がないんだと
自分という実感から見ると
そんなに影響はないんだと
例えば あなたは人を殺しちゃったんだから
今くよくよ悩んでるでしょうと
まあそのうち消えるんだと
そのうち消える場合もあるでしょうと
もし魂に影響あるんだったら絶対消えないはずなんですけど
消えることがありますから
ということで私がいる
でも私には善行為の影響はないと決める場合もあります
もう一人の人が私がいると言っても
楽しい時は楽しいし いろんな時はもう悩んだり苦しんだりするし
人を殺しちゃったらかなり後悔したりするし
自信がなくなっちゃうし
私っていうのはかなり影響を受けるんだと
[笑い]やっぱり行為に結果あるんだと
だから悪いことをしたら私という自我が悪い結果になって
いいことをしたら私という自我が悪い結果になるんだと
ある人はこういう論を語る
私的なそれは全ておかしい
間違ってる だからこういう論を語るんだからって
仏教と似ているんだっていうのは
そんなのは甘い話なんです
仏教のこういう論 功論っていうのはぜったく全く全く違うんです
もともとも実体ないという状態で語ってるんだから
そこでものの流れ 隙間なく確認する人にとってはいろいろ条件によってものは変化していること
見えて見えて見えて見えて見えて見えて
なんとなく法則発見できるんです
例えば 自分の手に止まった虫を見た瞬間で
あ 嫌だと思った時と また考えて
やっぱり間違いなく仏教をやってるんだから
そう思ってはあかんなと思ったところで
これも生命ではないかと思ったところで
何のことなくかわいくなってしまったとか
それぐらいのことでも因果法則わかるでしょうに
そうやってどんな煩悩が生まれるかと
そのように 因果法則見えてくる
それだけじゃないんです
一つの現象消えると必ず次の現象があるんです
止まらないんです だから近接因ですか
一番近い原因で見ちゃうともうわかるんですよ
これなくなったら次にこれでしょうと
だから近い原因だったらもうほとんどわかるんです
例えば あの 何て言いますか
ガラスを落ちたとすると
落ちたならば割れるということはわかるし
割れるならば落とすということもわかるでしょうに
そこで破片になったガラスがガラスているか破片になるかと
ガラスが割れたら破片になる
だから一つの現象 ガラスという現象が消えちゃったんです
消えちゃったんだけど
破片という現象がそこに生まれたんです
そこでカラスの声というものが生まれるんです
生まれると耳に触れると必ずその聴覚という現象が生まれるんです
やめられますかね それは
やめられないんです だから現象の流れ
それで一つ生まれるためには
一番近い原因は？生まれる現象の前の現象がなくなることなんです
で それはこのわかりやすくするんだけど
音の場合も同じことですけどね
音のエネルギーが耳に触れて
耳がそれを吸収しないと音としては聞こえませんね
ですから そこで音は死んじゃうんです
死ななかったら聞こえませんよ
だからこの ものすごい複雑でもうすごい世界だから
それを説明するのは難しいんですけど
ものによって因果法則の説明は変えなくちゃいけないんです
ですから わかりやすい因果法則で言えば
ガラスという現象がある
次に破片という現象が
ガラスが死んだ 破片が生まれたんです
隙間がありますか？ないんです
間がないんです ガラスを割れて １
時間経ったところで破片になったということはないんです
隙間がなく 次の現象が出てくる
そこでガラスと破片はまるっきり同じものですかね
同じじゃないんです 特色は違う
ガラスという現象の作用は違う
現れ方 ガラスはガラスで見えますからね
かっこよくて それも違う
で ガラスはガラスである原因もそれなりで違う
破片もまた違う 破片の特色は違う
ガラスは触っても怪我しませんだけど
破片触っちゃうと怪我したりまでする
ガラスには水は入れられますけど
破片には何も入れられません
そうやって Lakkhana paticca anupada dhātu はガラスと破片とは違うんですね
だから原因は原因で 破片の原因はガラスなんですね
ガラスですよ ガラスから破片が生まれたと
で そういう例でわかると思いますけど
それをわかるための例であって
もっと厳密ですから 事実の流れはね
一つ消えるということは
もう一つ生まれることであって
そこに実体は入りません
音の場合も 一つの音を聞くと
もう一つの音は聞こえないんです
そういうことだから この何もないのに
自分もないのに 現象っていうのはやっぱりその時のその時の条件によって止まることなく流れていくんだと
だからある面で私には私は死んじゃったらもう将来あるんだと言った人には
あんた邪教を言ってるんだと言うんです
それは邪見だと 私は死んじゃったらそれで終わりと
生まれませんと言ったら
あなたは邪見だと 言いながら我々はものの流れ
現象の流れを言ってるんです
私はもともともないと
なぜならば滅しますから
なくなるんだから 次に生まれるのはもうほとんど別なものなんですけど
前のものから生まれたんだから
で 関連性もあると やって
全く自我のない 主体のない
単なる自然の万物の現象の流れだけ体験している
終わりなく流れていくんだと
それで輪廻転生の問題は解決する
私が生まれ変わります
という問題ではなくて
こんな調子だったら この心の流れは止まるわけないんだと
瞬間も心は止まりませんと
じゃあ心は体に沿って体なしに行動しないかと
だったら体壊れたら心は止まるんだけど
体と関係なくも心は動いていることは
その時体験しているならば
体もそれなりに心も別なエネルギーだと
体は別なエネルギーだと
まあ最後に最初にそれ理解するんだからね
お互いに依存しているんだけど
別々やってることはわかりますからね
輪廻の問題もそこで解決します
そこでほとんどの宗教で哲学で言っていることはもう興味がなくなっちゃうんです
まあ何のこともないんだと
これ単純なこれわかってないんだから
この感覚の問題でどのように感覚が生まれてくるかと
どのように煩悩が生まれてくるかと
こういうことをわかってないんだから
そういう哲学も宗教もいろいろあるんだと
やっぱりあるのはドッカとそれによる渇愛と
無常見えない無明で もうそればっかりでもう流れてるだけですよということで
やっと死生体のことに納得いくんですね
で それでもう一切の他の思想やら哲学やら宗教に対するもう答えがその人に出てきてます
捨てるとか何とかではなくて
その人にとってはあんた間違ってるんだっていうのではなくて
実はこういうことですよ
その答えが出てくるんです
だから答えが出てきたんだから
その人は他人と喧嘩もしない
その人々の気持ちわかるんだから
神様を確実に創造したんだという人にも喧嘩しません
その人の あの 何て言いますか
この エカブーティニャーナじゃなくとも
ちょっとワリドの言葉ありますね
マニカー あの ヨーニソマニカーラがないんだからと
如実に物事を考えてないんだから
まあ大雑把で感覚で煩悩に左右されて感情に侵されて考えてるんだから
そういう妄想が生まれるだけということがわかりますね
まあしょうがないと だから別にこの疑いを乗り越える状態になったところで
まあ鉄砲を持っても機関銃を持ってみんなに撃ちまくっていくかといえば
そんなことはしません
だから誰とも喧嘩作りません
そういうことで これは疑いの乗り越える順番だと言えます
その状態になった人は本当は
チュウラソーターパーナというんですね
初預流果と称されると
あの このページのこのの上 の行で書いてあるんですね
それはこの初乗論で そこまで悟ったら
まあ小さ なんて言いますか
初預流果だと 大体もうそこからはまた邪教に陥るとかね
逆戻りはしないんですね
まだ悟ってないんです
そこまで分かったらもう大変な知恵だから
でもただ確認することだけ真面目にやれば
その知恵が出てきます
あまり物事をうるさく言わないで確認する人々がね
やっぱり私は説法していないにも関わらず
かなりかえって私に説法するんですね
こういうことはこういうことだ
こういうことはこういうことだと
私も楽しく聞いたりはします
だから本人ね 何のことなく
もう頭が冴えてきて 物事を見えるようになっちゃいますから
で あの ちょっとあの そこが難しいんですから
ちょっと何とか取ろうかなと思いますけど
あの 分 分ぐらい休憩して始まります
[咳]一切の固定概念
一切の人間の感情 もう全て終わりと
もう今まで勉強したものも
哲学も宗教も全部もう捨てちゃうんですね
それで小さなレベルの小型の預流果として見ているんです
まあただ人間でいえばもう赤ん坊生まれたんだというぐらいのこと
まだまだ人間になってないんです
大人になってないんです
ですから そこまでこのレベルまで来ると
これ大変なことなんです
大変なことというのは
ものすごいすごい素晴らしいことなんです
そこまで来たかないかということは
この確かめる方法はあるんです
大体そんな哲学は瞑想ではやりません
ただ単なる確認することだけだから
例えば人が何か違う意見言ったりする
あんた知ってますか？あの弥勒があっちこっちで現れてるんだって
今世紀末だから それはもう写真もありますよと
あのどこかでまあジースが現れたんだとかね
言うと自分の心はどうですかと
本当かなと思っちゃったら
やっぱりまだまだ ではなくて
その人の話を聞いて ああ
そういうことで そういうことで
こういうことで こういうこと
あんた方こういうこと言ってるんだと
とすぐ理解できるならば
もしその人に反論したいと思う
そうすると厳密に論理的に初めて聞いたのに
その話はこういうことで
こういうことで こういうことで
これはおかしいと言えるんだったら
まあそのレベルになります
まあもっとわかりやすく
もっとわかりやすい言葉で言えば
いかなる哲学者 いかなる科学者が来て
お釈迦様おっしゃっている四聖諦と因果法則と関係ない
どんな話 どんな実験データ持ってきたっても
自分にはそれは間違ってるよと言えるんだと
ただ感情で間違ってるんで
私は仏教信仰してるんだから
そんなものはゴミと同じですからね
そんな考え方 そうじゃなくて
きちんとこういうわけで
こういうわけで こういうことでしょうと
すぐ発見できる 瞬時に
この人々の思考の流れとどこで間違っているかという
それぐらいこのいつでも弁論できるんですね
何も概念を持たない自分の状況を弁論できる
それを同じく仏説の弁論にもなります
そういうことで能力あるならば
まあそのところには行ってるんですね
なんかかすかにでも見えがあるんだったら
まだ頑張った方がいいんですね
そこは確かめるポイントなんです
だから この人の言動とか
突然何か想像できない質問を出してきたりとかね
我々もしますけどね で
時々これいちいちそれに感情的になって
こうで もうこっちは関係ない
質問が出したから出したんだけど
違うものをチェックしているんですね
そこでもう×出したらもう関係ないと
まあそこはそのレベルなんですね
だからもう大雑把なものじゃなくて
しっかりした知恵のレベルなんです
次のステップステージはマッガーマッガニャーンダッサのミソディ32 294 ページの
で こちらの説明は皆様それなりに
お読みになってください
一応基本的なところだけ説明します
こちらで道と非道 道を決めるんです
これからなんです 仏道に行くかないかっていうことは
もう知恵があっても 仏教の論理は正しいということ
もうしっかり自分で納得しているんですね
で これから道を決めなさいと
やるかやらないかと そういう状態
そんなような話なんです
と言ったっても この人はものすごい長い間厳しく修行してこないと
このステージまで来ないんですよ
ディッティビスッディマゲーは来ないんです
ディッティビスッディとカンカービトルに来たら
その人はもう諸預流果であって
仏道からは離れません
たとえ怠けたっても離れませんだけど
悟りという解脱という立場から見て
あんたもう決めなさいということなんですね
で そこで決めちゃったら
本当に出世間的な もう悟りの境地にチャレンジ
今まではまあごく普通に仏教は理解して
心の問題を解決したいというぐらいのことなんですね
これからはもう輪廻そのものを乗り越えて
もう解脱の方に行くか行かないかという判断の指摘なんですね
でもここまで来る人はやっぱり瞑想はし続ける
瞑想し続けると ただ瞑想は同じ
ただ確認していく 確認していくと
ちょっとこの重点をちょっとずらさなくちゃいけない
もう因果法則もわかっている
それはいくら見ていたっても同じことなんです
カラスの音が耳に触れる
嫌な気持ちが生まれてくる
もう面白くもううるさいと思うし
また消えていく それから落ち着いてくる
またカラスが鳴くとまた
そこはもう分かったんだから
いくら軽く繰り返したっても同じことなんです
痛みが生まれてくる それで確認する
それでちょっと嫌にもなってくる
それで痛みが消えてくる
それでまた瞑想やりたくなってくるとかね
それで因果法則はいくら見ても同じことなんですね
そればっかり見ていると
さらに知恵が開発で余裕が出てくるんですね
余裕が出てくると何が見えるかというと
ここで初めて無常・苦・無我という 3つの三唱の一つ
自分の個人差で一つ取らなくちゃいけない
で 大体誰にでも無常は掴まることは簡単
ある人々に ある人々にドゥッカ苦しみ見ることもできます
すごい知恵の鋭い人々に無我を感じることはできます
だからってそちら差がないんで 3つも同じなんです
そこでこのどのように見るかというと
カラーパという言葉がありまして
このカテゴリーでグループで見るんですね
例えばカラスの声が耳に触れると
で そこで感情が生まれてくる
次に膨らみ縮みに行くと
また違う感情で あれも消えちゃったんですね
あれはなくなったと それでいきなりウグイスの声も入ったとする
それで膨らみ縮み見ていた感情とはまた違う感情が生まれてくる
それで声が消えちゃう
そうやって物事は このセット
ガラスの声と その嫌な気持ちまでのセット
セットが生まれて消えていっちゃったと
それでウグイスの声と気持ちいい感情と
そのセットが生まれて消えちゃうと
だから一つのセットが生まれて
それ消えたら次のセットが始まるんですね
膨らみを見たらそのセットなんですね
それに自分の感情も全部ありますけど
それ終わったら次のセット
縮みのセットが始まっちゃうんですね
ダブってないんだと だから一つ消えると一つ生まれる
それは無常を見ることなんですね
単なる無常だ 無常だ 無常だ
無常だって それはもうヴィパッサナー瞑想ではないんです
そういうのは俗世間にある
ごく普通な宗教の世間にある
もう一つのごまかしの瞑想にしか何もないんです
そうやってこの厳密に
例えば音を一粒一粒の無常がまだまだわからないかも
そこまでわからなくてもいいんです
セットでいいんです 例えば痛みが生まれたらと
この痛み全部セットで
それで痛みが消えると違う感覚ですから
だからセットセット確認していくと
やっぱり一つ消えていって
次の 次にこれ 次にこれという感じなんですよ
だから次にこれ 次にこれ確認するんだ
次にこれ確認するんだということになっちゃうと
やっぱり次から次へと消えていくんだと
消えていくんだということをわかるんですね
それぐらいのドゥッカの
そんなに難しい大変な無常の感じではないんです
でも痛みがあると 痛みだけは消えてほしい
楽になってほしいというと
これは欲の世界で この時点になってくると
本物の客観観察者になってもらわないと無常は見えない
主観で無常願ったっても
あれは本物の無常じゃないんです
だから我々知ってる無常は本物じゃないんです
そこで痛みがあると 本当に強烈な痛みで我慢できないほど
これだけはなくなってほしいとか思っちゃうと
やっぱりそこで主観が入っていて
そこで気持ち痛みが消えちゃった
これああ良かったと不思議やと驚いたりして
そこに囚われたりして
そういう人にも無常はわからないんですね
本物じゃないんですね
だから何があろうとも冷静な気持ちで見てると
これ見て次にこれでしょうと
次にこれ 次にこれでしょうという感じなんですね
痛みが生まれたから 痛み
痛みと 消えたか じゃあ膨らみ縮みやと
という感じで なんとなく心がこのセットセットで見ているんだから
この無常という方向に行っちゃうんです
あるいは ある人にとっては
この確認して確認してもうもううるさくて
もう嫌で もう何見たってもめんどくさくて
全てうるさいと感じるかもしれませんね
音が来るわ そこはまた確認しなくちゃいけない
それから違う感じが生まれるわ
それ確認しなくちゃいけない
膨らみが確認しちゃうと
次に必ずもう縮みが始まっちゃうし
それをやらなくちゃ それで終わるまでにまたもう膨らみが始まっちゃうし
確認することも大変であるし
で 確認するとうまくいったり
うまくいかなかったりするし
そうするとまた嫌になったりもしちゃうし
そうやってもうやっぱりもうドッカやと
結局はと 切りがなく流れるんだというふうに
この価値観から見ちゃうとドッカなんですね
価値観なしに単なるまあ次にこれ
次にこれやと あまりにも価値観なく機械みたいに確認すると無常に見えるんですね
だから本当にどう見たってもやっぱりかなりややこしくてうるさいもんだと
めんどくさいことやと
ちちめんどくさいことやと
もう生きることをいろいろ認識
認識 認識 認識ばっかりで
これが生きることかと
というふうな感じで見ちゃうと
その人はドッカを確認しているんですね
そういう気持ちでラベリングしていると
まあ個人的に別に苦しみあって瞑想を始めたわけでもなくて
奥さんに逃げられてヴィパッサナーに来たわけでもない場合は
普通のこの知識を智慧を目指して来る人々にとっては
本当に真実とは何ですかという気持ちで見てるんだから
実体がないんだからね
どうせもうその時のその時の幻覚だけでせという気持ちで
次にはこの幻覚やと 幻想だと
今は痛みの幻想だと それ終わっちゃったら次のはこういう幻想だと
というふうな感じで見ると無我なんです
こちらで説明していたのはそういうことなんです
専門用語でずっと だからセットでセットで確認してみてくださいと
するとズルズルと心は無常か空か無我を見られるようになるんです
だからって無常だ無常だ空だ空だ空だ無我だ無我だと言ったっても
まあ食われて終わっちゃうだけ
何も智慧の方に行かない
これももう いや もうあるのはこれだけというふうな結論として出てくるものなんです
あるのは無常だけですよ
そこで無常を発見するためには
この確認するときは確認の仕方がつあります
で 三相ですね 無常 苦 無我
その中で個人が一つですよ
それは自分で選ばなくてもいいんです
自分の認識の世界だから
自分では何がわかるかと自動的になるんだからね
それからどうやって発見しますかと
まずセットでセットで見てみましょう
セットは簡単ですね 痛みのセット
カラスの声のこの聴覚のセット
で 昏眠来たっても昏眠のセット
そうやってセットセットで見やすいんだから
そのように見ましょうと
それから流れで見ましょうと
例えば膨らみが出てきて
次に必ずしも隙間なく縮みが生まれてきて
それから隙間なくもう次に膨らみが
だから全く膨らみと縮みというのは全く別なものでしょうに
例えば痛みが出てきて
それ消えちゃって また軽く楽になってしまって
それからまたしびれがどこかに出てきて
だからこれいろいろ違うんですけど
とにかく一つ終わると次にもう一つが出てくる
それが次にもう一つ出てくる
そうやって流れで見ると
流れで見るともう無常ということに気がつくんですね
それからこの時間で見ると
[鐘の音]であんまり激しく時間で見るっていうことはね
どうかな 時間って見るっていうか同じことが前はこれでした
今はこういうことを確認してるんだ
それはって言ったら次はこれ確認したんだ
そしたら時間なんですね
時間の場合は過去現在未来って３つなんですけど
未来は確認しないんだからね
で 過去は確認できるし
ですから一つ確認したらそれ過去に行っちゃう
次のこと確認したらそれも過去に行っちゃうと
そうやって時間の経過として見ると
また現象が生まれて消えるんだ
生まれて消えるんだって無常は出てくるんですね
あるいは仏教的な知識があるならば
このシャナ セツナ セツナもすごい感じやすいもんですよ
そんな難しいことじゃない
例えばこの音にしたっても
ずっと瞬間瞬間瞬間この一粒一粒一粒で流れているということはね
感じようすりゃ感じられます
音にしたっても同じことで
他のものにしても 例えば膨らみにしたっても
この膨らみという大きなセットではなくて
膨らんで膨らんで膨らんで膨らんで膨らんで膨らんで膨らんでいくということをね
足が運ぶことにしたっても
足がそのそのとこ そのとこ
そのとこで違う違う違う違う変化を起こして起こるんですよ
例えば足が運ぶ場合は上げたということには仕事をたくさんなるんですね
その瞬間 その瞬間で感覚は違うんですよ
そこで伸ばす場合も 一つ一つ一粒一粒違うんだと
で 下ろす時も まあただ一般に下ろしたってことじゃなくて
ゆっくりゆっくりゆっくりこの瞬間
瞬間 瞬間 感覚違うんだと言われて
そういう風にこの刹那刹那で見ることもできます
これ結構私はスローモーション強調するのは
この刹那で見えてくるかなということなんです
スローモーションで動かしてみると
この一つは大雑把でではなくて
きめ細かくきめ細かくいろんなものをつなげてつなげて現象が生まれるということが見えてきます
そういう方法で無常見るんです
で この無常か苦か無我ということに強調するためには
例えば超スローモーションで瞑想してみる
座ってる時はスローモーション関係ないんだけど
その時も膨らみも明確に膨らみという
この感覚 一つ一つ一粒一粒一粒一粒取って感じなくちゃいけない
それにはすごく集中力はものすごく必要なんです
ほんのわずかでも焦っちゃったらスローモーションできません
ですから集中力は生まれていきます
一応心は自我があるんだ
魂があるんだ 創造した唯一の神様が発見するんだ
ブラフマン発見するんだという方向ではなくて
まあやっぱり無常だ無常だという方向に行くんだから
もう仏道なんですね 真我を真の魂を発見するんだと
梵我一如を体験するんだって思っちゃったら
もう邪教に行っちゃうんです
この瞑想は だから無常を見なさいと
で 無常でなければ何も存在しないということは
この時点でわかっているはずなんです
だから 何の混乱なく 疑いなく無常に入られます
で 入るためにも入ってもすごい集中力は必要なんです
集中力なくなっちゃったら
全部まとめてもうあるという風にまたなってしまっちゃう
それで集中力が出てくると
いろいろトラブルが起こるんですね
このトラブルはヴィパッサナーウパッ記で33で297ページに書いてます
例えばこの 2週間  1週間
10日間ぐらい続けて真面目に瞑想しちゃうと
ほとんどこのヴィパッサナーのこれ何と読みますか
感応 汚染 で 汚染は生まれるんです
洗脳で感応洗脳というものを生まれてくるんですね
これは大変この邪魔なんです
そこを引っかかったらもう一歩も進めないんです
そこでストップ止まっちゃうんです
だから気をつけなくちゃいけない
1番目は光オーバーセ
すごく光見えてくる で
光もいろんな方向を見えますけど
例えば目を閉じたら光という風に見える場合もあるし
目を開けてもものすごく明るく
暗闇に至っても もう全部もう明るく明確にもう部屋の電気なくても机もどこにあるかというぐらいもう明確に見えると
そうやって客観的に光が現れる時もあります
だからこの まあ例えば暗闇で歩く瞑想しているんだと
まあそこまで進んでいるんだったら
いきなり暗闇が消えちゃうんですよ
消えて綺麗に光があって
もう歩くところは綺麗に見えてるんですね
で見えても歩けるんですね
で そうやっていろんな形であの光が現れちゃうんですね
だから主観的な光だったら頭おかしいとかなんとかでも言えますけど
客観的な光だったったら結構ややこしいんですね
あなた頭おかしいと言っても
本人には暗闇で見えるんだから
だからどうしてもその時はああ良かったという気持ちが生まれてくるんです
で そこで瞑想が止まっちゃうんですから
すごく気をつけなくちゃいけない
2番目はオーバー 書いてないかな
ヴィパッサナーサッリプッタ
これは日本語でしか書いてない
2番目は喜と書いてますね
オーバーピーティ すっごく楽しくなっちゃうんですね
もう楽しみが湧いてくるんです
やる気が出て楽しくて楽しくて
こんな楽しみがないんだ
これは要注意なんです
やっぱりみんな何やってるんですかって
ヴィパッサナーやるべき
こんなに楽しみはないでしょうとやって
すごい強烈に楽しみが生まれてくる
ヴィパッサナーピーティ
次にファッサディ それで 3番目の汚染は
まあ汚染と洗脳は あの
今まで苦労して苦労して瞑想したんだけど
心も軽いし体も軽くて
もうやりたい放題瞑想できるんです
かすかにでももう眠気もないし
体はもう 2時間であろうか
3時間であろうか 座れるわ
重さはまるっきりない体に
浮いてるような感じ そうやってすっごく楽になってしまっちゃう
そういうのはものすごいあの強烈なんです
強烈に出るんです 次 何でしたっけ？あの確信
それからこの まあ仏教に対してすっごい確信
やっぱり仏教だと やっぱりこれこそやとすっごい確信が出てくる
信仰がものすごく強くなってくる
で サッダ それからサッダと
アディモッカ サッダというよりはアディモッカなんですね
アディモッカだから確信
あ 確信ですね ものすごくやる気が出てくる
次になんて言うんですか？日本語は
サク？サクレイ パッラーハっていうのはものすごい頑張っちゃうんですね
もうとことん瞑想に頑張りたくて頑張りたくてもうすごい力が生まれてくる
それであるいはすごく落ち着いてサク
あの楽しくてしょうがないっていうことじゃなく
すごい気持ちよく ものすごく落ち着いて楽しくサクになっちゃうんですね
もう何にも動揺しないで
すごく気持ちよく 楽しく楽にいるようになる
それから次の問題はものすごい鋭い智慧が生まれてくる
何でも厳密に見てしまおうと
で 最後にはあの まだあります
で 智慧が出ている それからアンジュというこのサマーディが生まれてくるんですね
ずっともうサマーディがあって落ち着いていられると
スカーン パッタナー ウペッカー
ニカン で それからサマーディ
シャーですね ウペッカーが生まれてくる
ウペッカーっていうのは
まあベースに何にも気にしない状態になっちゃうんですね
まあ無常だからね あまり気にしないと
すごいウペッカーが出るんですね
それも危ないんです 最後は本当はニカンって言ってる言葉で欲が生まれるんですね
何に欲が生まれるんですか？自分の修行に対する
自分がよく頑張ったんだと
こんな瞑想はすごくいいものだと
ヴィパッサナーっていうのは立派なもんだと思うことは
もうここまで成長したんだから
やっぱりすごくいいものだと
やっぱりやりたいというふうに欲が生まれてくるんです
そこで本人にはさっぱりこれは間違ってるとわからないんですね
[鐘の音]ですから 一応集中力生まれると
多かれ少なかれ一つ二つは体験しなくちゃ
体験するんです この十種類あります
この十種類の中に一つ二つは大体は体験しちゃうんです
そこはできればまあ一日で終わってもらわないと
あるいは二 三秒で 一分
二分でその状況をやめてもらわないと
もうそこでピッタシとストップなんです
そういう風にストップになったり
人々は結構見てきたんです
そこまでももう何年も修行なんですよ
何年もヴィパッサナーやってそこまで来るんですけど
そこに来たら何か光が見えたとか
サマーディが生まれたとか
すごい確信が生まれたとか
そこでストップやっちゃう
それ言いたくて言いたくて
人に だから そこでまたそういう人々は諦めずに瞑想もします
よく瞑想する ちょっと暇があったらすぐ瞑想に入ってくる
子供たちと喧嘩までして
もうすぐ道場に行って瞑想に行っちゃうとかね